welcome to the lobby I am your host
Chris Waters filling in for Daniel dwire
who's on vacation in his homeland now
before I introduce the gentleman sitting
next to me I want to tell you a little
bit about the show today we've got some
great games that are finding their way
to new platforms Rogue Legacy and the
swapper and we're also going to talk
about our contest to give away
PlayStation
4's plural but all that's going to come
a little later and first I wanted to
talk about some big news that hit
Gamespot here last week as many of you
already may know many people who help
Define Gamespot as a site are no longer
with us and I want to help you to I want
you to help me join them in giving them
a proper farewell we're going to miss
the editorial Acumen of Carolyn Pettit
Tom McShay and Maxwell McGee as well as
the production Wizardry of Warner Von
gof Bonito Gonzalez and Jan hair Justin
Calvert's leadership helped to find the
editorial vision of the site for over a
decade and Sharon Goslin right from the
very beginning helped make everyone here
look good with her awesome copy editing
and of course there's Ryan McDonald a
man whose growth as a leader and
production Ace mirrored the growth of
GameSpot itself I know I speak for
everyone here when I say we're going to
miss these folks and we can't wait to
see what new adventures they get up to
and I can't wait to see what new
adventures we get up to as well because
as any of you who have followed the site
for a while know change is a constant
around here from new shows and new
editorial features to evolving news
coverage and a whole site
redesign with your feedback and with the
passionate people who work here we're
going to really try to continue to make
Gamespot a place where people who are
passionate about games love to come and
love to talk about games and speaking of
some of those guys two dudes who are
passionate about Games Brad Shoemaker
and sha mckinness hi guys I am yeah yeah
well I mean you it says it on your say
on your bio that's why you wanted me
here okay hey I have a passion for your
ability to memorize extended monologue
that was pretty good right yeah I had
that uh I jotted it down uh you know I
wanted to make sure I didn't uh make any
boner jokes because I don't want to take
away Danny's thing right kind of that's
that's an Odo signature you don't want
to steal his boner Thunder all right uh
speaking of games with Boner jokes and
then Rogue Legacy Rogue Legacy does it
have boner jokes in it it's got to right
yeah may it might or is it just more
irreverent humor I don't know anyways
this is a game that's been out for a
little while on PC but now you are
playing it Sean on the uh Playstation 4
uh this is actually one of the PS4 PS3
PS Vita uh cross platform games and it's
cross Save which is one of my favorite
things about it so I've been able to
play on my V while traveling and play it
on my PS4 at home it's uh it's the first
game where I've really gotten into the
whole cross saave functionality it's the
first game I can think of that's done
cross saave right oh yeah like most of
the games that have are cross saave
enabled you have to dig through options
menus and like find a sync function or
whatever like if you play this game on a
new platform it immediately says Hey
like the save data is not as new as the
one in the cloud do you want to play the
one in the cloud you say yes and like
you're off the races like please super
streamlined yeah it's super painless too
so I am going to I think there's a
little hidden area secret there buddy
you are you are oh yeah hidden hidden
chest nicely done yeah uh I'm not sure
if we cut to it in time but basically
when you see these little dark gray
spots in the ground that means it's a
little hidden area and then I go and
start whacking stuff that chest was
invisible a second ago so that you
unlocked a rune there and Rogue Legacy
is a Rog like in the sense that it you
know every run you start from scratch
but that's not quite accurate the cross
save you know matters because you build
this Castle yeah it's a huge aggression
game um oh God it's a Rog like with
persistence which is kind of an oxymoron
yeah but uh Rog like like I mean I think
they call it a rogue light depending on
how twe you want to get with your your
terminology Hy little names for things
yeah so I beat the game already and I'm
on New Game Plus right now which is
which means which means that I'm going
through the castle a second time means
all the enemies are different colting
they like much much tougher enemies uh
you can tell I'm actually level 180
right right now so played a pretty good
amount of Rogue Legacy a [__] yeah not
bad uh is this red sword one of those
vampire swords what takes the health
from the enemies no um but I do have
some some runes that allow me to do that
I'm at the point where I actually get
like four HP and four MP for every kill
which is which is pretty handy that's
pretty crucial for like survivability in
this game oh yeah yeah oh [__] if you
guys have any questions about Rogue
Legacy go ahead and tweet them to at
gamespot.com put them in the chat on the
site and uh we'll relay them here I I I
bet a lot of you guys out there have
played this game a bunch as have I I
only got to be the first boss though so
I don't know if that classifies as a
bunch so when the big eyeball dude yeah
is this your first time uh playing the
game no I played it on PC and I beat the
eyeball boss but that's that's that's
where it starts and ends for you yeah
yeah yeah what about you Brad uh I beat
the second boss I think on the PC M I
just kind of put it down for one reason
or another but all in on the uh PS4
version now4 version are you not a v man
no I've got it on the V I've just mostly
been playing it at home for for whatever
reason but uh you know if God forbid I
haven't finished this game by the time
Pax rolls around this will definitely be
an airplane game for me that is just a
few that's like what three weeks away
far yeah it's not far but you guys have
uh big packs thing planned naturally
stuff is coming together yeah excellent
well we'll get you to jibber jabber
about that a little bit more uh I don't
know maybe in in a closer to pack show
yeah yeah once we know what the hell
we're doing
which would maybe which was maybe going
to be like 45 minutes before it all goes
down yes that's typically how it goes
yeah that's how it goes for us anyway I
think last last year we were up to like
an hour and a half so nice we're getting
there progress all right so Sean like
the when you're actually playing the
game you start off without the ability
to like double jump or Dash but pretty
quickly you get like your core set of
abilities and then it's there's there's
not a lot of them though it's not like
you can use all sorts of different moves
here it's like sword jump maybe Dash and
use some magic I'm going to go ahead and
sacrifice myself so that we can check
out like the uh the character selection
stuff cuz that's kind of if you guys
haven't played Rogue Legacy that's so
much the Crux of what makes the game
interesting you thought you were done oh
yeah so there you go that's actually one
one ability that I've unlocked in the
game so I've been slain so Rogue Legacy
yeah game give it to me that's all about
family Chris family you die and you get
to select which one of your children you
get to play as which one of your chosen
progyny will lead now unlike uh most
families you actually can reroll your
children if you unlock the ability to
reroll your children roll your children
no Sean technically it's not exactly
legal no that's just getting a divorce
and starting a new family with other
kids that you love more yes um so I I've
got two favorite classes like there you
can you start with I think what is it
like three basic classes
yeah and then you unlock much more
specialized ones as the game goes on um
my favorite the Splunk is good for
that's really weak but you collect a lot
of gold um a hero for hoarders but this
one is fun too the how do you pronounce
it hok hok hok yeah I was going to say
Hokage come on man it's not French this
ain't nuto it's Nar as Shoemaker knows
H is on point I'll talk about that all
right all right what I so and then this
is uh if you've never played Rog liky
this is also a feature that makes it
very different from other Rog likes
because there is all this persistence so
I can upgrade like my maximum equipment
weight or my armor or this is where like
you unlock new like that death defy when
I came back from the death before yeah
that's because every time I die I have a
3% chance of coming back so basically
you got really lucky and then sacrificed
that chance so that we could just look
at this stuff so I'm going to upgade
this make it a four 4.5% chance and then
I'm going to put a little bit oh this
this is good so it'll cost 2,900 to
improve my health and I have 29 81 right
now so yeah the the occasionally
frustrating thing is that you sacrifice
most or all of your gold when you go
back in the castle Yeah Yeah so you got
you got to spend all the way down if you
can because you're just going to throw
away whatever you don't spin uh so this
is my setup that I've got that the
Dragon Sword is what you were asking
about earlier basically this is just a
super high damage sword that's really
really [__] heavy it's a pretty boss
sword yeah so it takes up a lot of
weight and weight is just how much you
can carry yeah right exactly but if I
wanted to do like full vampirism I've
got like the blood sword and like the
blood Helm and all that stuff so I mean
you unlock can you just vampire yourself
up and then we'll send Brad in as the
vampire shoe maker I could go super
vampire and then there's also the runes
which allow me to like get like four
different double jumps if I wanted to do
that that seems excessive so you can
spec yourself into some really really
have enough double jump Waters come on
is that not it's four double jumps just
four jumps or is it eight
jumps uh it's just it's just four jumps
oh I don't know man quadruple jum you're
asking questions we're not equipped to
answer uh yeah and then so like Brad
said any leftover money that you have
you have to give to this guy to pay your
toll to get through the castle again
that dude's name is death right and one
of the upgrades is that you can Sharon
you can reduce the number of cash so I
only give him 90% of my cash yeah hold
on to those nine gold that's going to
help you out big
time um and it's not the castle hson
like the they're they're you can see on
that map there four there are four areas
the areas are always you know going to
be the same kind of like
enemy uh variety and tile set but the
map is different every time yes exactly
so this first room is very different
from how it was last time well unless
you there's that guy up front you can
pay right to like get the same one that
you just AR yeah you can lock the the
previous layout if you want although I I
never found a whole lot of use for that
I don't know about you guys that is
super helpful when you are committed to
beating a boss and you always want to
warp to where the boss is does it uh
does it res the enemies that you killed
when you do that or are they all dead no
I think it I think the enemies are all
back oh okay that was fast that was fast
that was fast is this is this just
single new game plus it's not cuz I I
think there's a new game Plus+ right is
there this is but this is your second
run right this is my second run is
freaking brutal yes way worse Brad yes
want to get your hands on it give a shot
give a shot trust trust me to man handle
your safe file I now if you if you want
to reroll your children just hit the
touchpad oh what do we got here what is
glaucoma it's just it's dark this is the
other thing like the traits there are
random traits that like it you can yeah
you can have glaucoma so you can't see
as as far or like you're nearsighted or
farsighted and some of them are totally
consequential like you're gay or you're
bald or you fart randomly yeah you
randomly fart or you swear when you get
hit yeah or the or the castle looks like
Tron and then there's a one that just
turns it all upside down oh that would
never pick that one which is unplayable
you need to kill that bloodline that can
that Gene cannot be allowed to reproduce
are you going to do five double jumps
you not do you seriously not have a dash
uh I have a dash no actually I don't
what is that I haven't gone through I've
gone through the whole game without the
dash is that your only you only have the
one double jump I've got a few double
jump sorry man I got to get kitted out
here oh you can do the double jump if
you go to the blacksmith there's a
double jump Cape oh really yeah so go to
the black it's not the double jump It's
the dash that I want oh you want I don't
know how you don't play with that but I
got to figure out which Rune I can get
rid of for that how about let's see all
right Sean mean while Sean kits it out
gobu ride in the twitch chat wants to
know is there an end final boss there is
yeah I mean there's four initial bosses
and then there is a final boss mhm um
and but once you beat him that's what
triggers New Game Plus and you can just
replay the game a whole bunch of times
okay so this is my second playthrough
and I can already tell that I'm going to
replay the game a full second time and
is it I mean is it just because the
action is still so like it gets tougher
and it's really fun yeah it scales up
really well there's still a whole bunch
of unlocks and gear and stuff that I
haven't even got yet like when I beat
the game for the first time I had only
unlocked like maybe less than half of
the equipment so there's still still
like a pretty massive progression
there's still miles to go for the
Intrepid Adventurer Shawn mckinness and
his bloodline so remember or don't don't
forget since you've got the Barbarian
you can hit triangle for the dragon
shout
F that was actually a question we had
from yellow Sanchez was can you unlock
different shouts or is it maybe one
shout just the one shout for this
particular class but you can get
different Magics oh yeah well Magics
your abilities want that
gold I couldn't find the dash I so much
health I don't know which Rune that was
on but feel like I'm yeah without a dash
I'm lost in the darkness here without a
dash I feel
like that it's a tool it's a
maneuverability what's the deal I'm much
I'm a much bigger fan of jump more jumps
and the uh the health and Magic drains I
see that cuz especially when you're
playing as the Barbarian which is
essentially the tank you can go on some
epic epic runs if you are draining
Health with every kill you mean draining
it from enemies to resupply your endless
blood lust exactly yeah I mean the best
gold runs that I've ever had in this
game are as the Barbarian draining
Health not as the spelunk the the sort
of minor class that gets more gold per
per pound spelunk is capable definitely
of getting more but I just find with my
particular play style which is a little
bit more aggressive uhhuh with the
splunker or the Splunk at you have to
play really
defensively and you're just an aggro
kind of guy I'm an aggro kind of guy
that's why listen I just need to pop off
in there yeah I just got to pop oh yeah
those those guys shoot the bullets in
every direction Brad what about you man
what's your what's your uh who's your
jam I don't know that I've settled on a
favorite I'm still in the early phase of
the game where I'm just like grinding
out upgrades so I'd play a lot of the
miner or who's the kind of yeah first
form of the splunker but that's just to
get gold cuz I guess sucks
um I mean you know the obviously The
Barbarians the kind of the like you said
the one that's going to be the most
survivable I noticed that you guys
haven't like this this the problem that
I felt I ran into was like forgetting to
use magic or trying to be too cute with
it and like save my magic when really I
could have just used it and survived a
little longer so the uh the Lich King I
think it's Lich King right is that the
class that's one of the classes Arch May
AR it's the second form of the Lich um
you basically you gain Max Health every
time you kill and then your special
ability is you can turn your health into
more Mana yeah you just flip the bars
right so you'd have 400 mana and then
you just kill more guys and you and you
get that Health back up so like that's
who that's a good class to maximize your
magic usage with and that one's cool
because it actually increases your
maximum HP with every kill so you start
at like 120 HP or whatever and it
actually the bar actually increases
whereas with the Barbarian it starts
high and then so so far this has been
like we've discussed a bunch of sort of
different of the strategical elements in
the game you know different stats to
keep in mind different strategies do you
find that it's like when you first start
playing is it is it overwhelming at all
is it like I don't I don't understand
how all this works or it's not it's not
so much uh like grasping the concepts
but like there are so many upgrades when
you first start you know cuz every time
you buy an upgrade you unlock like three
more uh and something I didn't notice
the first time I played it is that each
time you buy an upgrade all the other
upgrades get more expensive
so you kind of need you need to pick and
shoes early on what you're put your
money in to because everything else is
going to get harder to get afterwards
that's what makes it hard to just kind
of like brute force your way through the
game is like upgrade strategy becomes
very important yeah your your build cuz
if you spread yourself too thin you can
make the game really tough on yourself
in terms of upgrades fight the boss
you're going to go to you got to fight a
boss you want to you're going to I
already beat this boss actually so is
this can I even so you can do like the
crazy high L yeah the crazy high High L
version of yes I think my I think my
path is clear yeah
NE fighting this guy inside Tron here's
your here's your Tron what happened to
my dude look how slowly his health is
going down with each hit there's no way
you're going which which person are you
now your character changed entirely also
Chang classes you have way less health
and your spells are all different what
just just happened is it but so that's
one of the special bosses like you
actually can come back after that yeah
can you just keep doing that yeah you
can but it's I've tried doing it like 10
times in a row and I made basically zero
progress is it the same character that
you like first beat the boss with maybe
um I I don't know actually that's one of
the games it's it's not a game that's
huge on secrets in the way that Spelunky
is but that's definitely one thing I
would classify as one of the game's
Secrets what is another thing you would
classify as one of the game secrets what
it's like to feel emotions sure I mean
that's you know that's the secret of
life itself and that's what Rog Legacy
is a microcosm
of yeah see now you just like you took
hell of hits from that thing oh yeah and
you're this guyy super tanked up also
I'm like so in my new game plus I've
beat the first two bosses which means
that I'm pretty high level for this area
we saw Brad go up to uh the area
directly above which is the Maya Maya
yeah he peaked his head in there and
then was having none of it the sequence
is like could you maybe go all the way
to the right and find or all the way
down and give us a glimpse of another
realm Brad you want to see
hell it's just the dungeons yeah it's
not hell oh it's not hell um so the
sequence in difficulty is this area of
the castle to the right is the forest
and then up is the Maya and then down is
dungeons take us to the forest Bradley
starting to look dicey you got you still
got 325 health and you're getting Health
with every kill so got to not die
oh here you go you're at the forest now
hey look oh yeah watch what is happening
down there oh my god oh [__] wow this is
the forest this is a different situation
this is one of the areas where when
there's a lot of
joking I hate these guys welcome to
Rogue Legacy new game plus it's a real
kick in the junk that was like a bullet
hell level oh yeah yeah well that's
that's where the uh the F Da comes in
super handy cuz it clears out all the
projectiles and is that just on a cool
down or does that take Mana it uses Mana
yeah uh you say Mana I say Mana let's
Call the Whole Thing
Off yeah pistol shrimp pistol shrimp way
better than the defaults on bumping that
pistol shrimp you guys know what a
pistol shrimp is pistol shrimp yeah a
rap name no like in addition to H Brad
shoemaker's rap name it's a shrimp that
like can shoot a part of its body so
fast that the water jet it creates just
like burns up I've heard that burns up
it's it's it's like it's some insanely
High degree of heat right yeah C nature
F I just want to point out I don't know
if there's any pistol shrimp in this
game what do you point out n Health
Brad's on a good run he's got 10,000
gold is that a is that going to is that
going to nice gold grabs is that going
to do you well oh yeah you can buy quite
a few upgrades of that and so why are
you going after this bad guy Brad is it
because you want that gold cuz gold I'm
an idiot yep greed Brad got to get mine
the unmaking of all men or or got to get
Sea's I guess Sean's I appreciate it
there you are all right that's that's
Rogue Legacy uh it's out been out on PC
for a while yeah now out on PS4 PS3 PS
Vita Cross by for like what 15 15 bucks
15 17 bucks something very good purchase
one low pr99 you guys giving it the
thumbs up it's such a good VA game
because it's great for just like all
right I'm going to play one quick
session I'm just one quick session which
inevitably turns into like eight but
still it's a and you've been standing in
your living room like not sitting on a
couch because you like came in the door
and you're like I just got to finish
this up yeah and then you still have
your backpack on like five minutes later
yep weird stuff Rogue Legacy uh Brad
Shoemaker thanks for coming on sharing
your expertise sha mckinness nicely done
you're gonna stick around we're gonna
have Kevin vanord and Justin hey Wald
come on in a minute talk about the news
because there's news and there's new
trailers and there's a new hyru Warriors
trailer I believe we are going to check
out right now yes Justin will'll let you
on in a second he's bobbing up and down
with excitement he's so so wonderful
we'll be back in a sec with news hyro
Warriors
now
k
h
I like how that art has like the
placeholders for you to do something
with your Wii I don't know what were
those gray boxes there you guys know for
YouTube right you like subscribe here
more videos it's the YouTube cool Hey
Kevin vanord hello it's Kevin vanord hi
Justin hawald howdy howdy hi guys uh
welcome to the show we're g to talk
about some news starting with some that
just broke like an hour or two ago yeah
so there was an Activision Financial
call this is today when the companies do
all their financial reporting and
exciting things like that and so we were
listening to them and they just kind of
dropped uh evolve going to come out in
February 2015 now 2K or Activision uh 2K
everybody oh sorry it's everybody's
Financial calls today act I just came
from the Activision one got it
everybody's calling their Finance guys
and like look man I can't I don't know
if I'm going to make this happen this
year I got to push evolve it's more it's
a big call that you sit in on and they
just talk about number it's really
boring but you can't but you have to do
it because you can get news out of it
yeah and every now and then they drop
something like this where evolve is
going to be pushed to 2015 the fact that
it comes during a financial call
probably says that this is more of a
financial reason than anything else it
is not a developmental reason that they
didn't run into some huge problem and
we've seen the game multiple times that
it it seems really close to being done
really it's in really good shape so far
it was not a game that you play and get
the impression like this could use a few
more months yeah you don't play that
game and think this needs more polish
that game looks really good and it plays
really well unfinished game I've ever
played probably so uh but a couple more
months to to make things a little bit
better isn't going to hurt it I'm sad uh
was there any new October's so crowded
like this this is better this is good
news all around October's a crazy
cluster F uh Sil though February is the
new October did they say February 2015
February 10th 2015 so okay so they gave
a proper date for it and did they say
anything about the beta because they
were going to do some exclusive Xbox one
type beta situation so this is more this
was definitely more on the investor
called like giving them information so
not for us I'm sure we're going to hear
some more information about a beta
coming up soon and how we how us
plebians will be able to get in and play
it but we don't have that morals Kevin
vanord you're a mere mortal I hate to
break it to you well at least I know
he's a god Path of Exile is a game
you've been playing a lot uh over the
over the past year and there's New Path
of Exile coming down the pipe yeah
there's an expansion coming out on the
20th so it's called forsaken Masters and
the whole deal is there like these seven
Masters that all uh that all opposed
Dominus who's the big who's the big bad
of Path of Exile so they were forsaken
they were forsaken yes and and I oh look
we're seeing some of the is that a
forsaken one yeah so master so the uh
the big thing for us was uh we we uh we
dropped a little exclusive on the third
master that was announced whose name is
Elon and he's kind of a martyr type guy
who likes punishment yeah I was reading
your article I like this uh masochism
stuff he's like H my church has forsaken
me now I just want to like die doing
something heroic he wants to die and
he's actually kind of pissed that every
time like the player comes in and
actually saves saves him and and and he
he's protecting The Relic so it's like
this whole thing where uh he's he's a
little he's a little pissy about being
alive these aren't people that you play
as these are like they have missions
associated with them new areas that you
explore um well not not really a new
area but you'll come across the seven
different ones as you go through so the
first time you play like on regular
difficulty you'll probably come across
each one of them either once or twice um
but as you keep going you'll you'll get
to do more and more stuff and then you
unlock a hideout which is kind of like
uh like kind of your guild Hall if you
want or your your player housing and
player house yeah do you get to
customize it or you get it's all simsy
is there a phase that like these sort of
massive games reach like the player
house threshold like once you've once
you've got a player house in there where
you can like buy a sofa to put in there
you've like jumped the shark like
they've gone player house no I don't
know like that that there was a time
when that was the kind of thing you just
expected from the beginning oh okay I
mean Anarchy Online you got like a house
from the very beginning and and uh you
know Everest 2 you got a house from the
beginning and like wildar yeah K's Epic
Yarn you have a house you have a house
SE I know MTI you two down at the end of
the couch are big Animal Crossing
so is this I mean there's a new house
you guys can customize are you in on
Path of Exile now I haven't been playing
Path of Exile but I am so much more
intrigued now that I get a house can I
like paint things and put in bring
animal friends in I haven't done that
whole like I haven't seen it in person
yet but my understanding is that there's
like a lot of Sims like you know like
customization can I pay off my life debt
to Tom Nook like is that a part of the
sequence or what I'm going to say yes
I'm going to say yes that's we're just
going to go with yes on let's go with
yes well I'm glad they've put that in
there uh having a house of course the
Ultimate Fantasy uh unrealizable fantasy
for anyone who lives in the Bay Area so
nice that I get to live that out in a
video game uh Kevin when can people play
when is forsaken Masters hit in Path of
Exile 20th 20th of August August 20th
thanks Sean August down echoing down the
way a 20 as some say August all right
Sean uh sorry Kevin again you're just
going to stay down there for a little
bit Sean actually you are going to pop
in on this one too because
I'm not going anywhere it's Assassin's
Creed
rou Rogue it's Assassin's Creed Rouge
and it's about how Maybelline is now the
new uh uh abstergo abstergo has got a
Cosmetics department now ex and uh it's
it's mind altering uh yeah so the only
thing we that was funny in my brain
there's a new game about work out once
it came out of my mouth we knew this was
coming I think code named Comet coming
up to this was the specifically the PS3
and Xbox 360 Assassin's Creed game that
they hadn't yet discussed and of course
the big you want to focus on Xbox One
PS4 PC because the the unity version is
the one that is going to look really hot
we got to see the basically a mood
trailer which is not the way the game is
going to look right it's a CG trailer it
shows off the new hero whose name is
Steve Rogue I think um no it's actually
just like Billy brother Shea patri
Cormac so he is a Templar he is an
assassin Hunter
So like um Assassin's Creed 4 was the
first game in the series where you're
actually not playing as an assassin for
the bulk of the game like eventually
Edward does become an assassin but he's
just doing his own thing for like 75% of
that game yeah he's he's basically Sarah
Palin he's going rogue yeah he's got
yeah ex there you go there's a there's a
Photoshop contest waiting to happen and
shooting Wildlife or in this case
assassins in this case people people
like yeah this guy who's just asking for
a hand so he's here's my question he's
actually stranded on this ice flow in
like the northern Atlantic yeah like
does he need to shoot him can't he just
leave him to die Sean if you if you
leave if you don't Smite him down he'll
come back stronger than you could ever
imagine I mean that's video game killing
one 101 yeah he's going to become an ice
monster he also he didn't kill him he
could still be alive he could have had a
moment of I'm going to shoot you no I I
want to be your friend or like I'll just
leave you to die and then later that
polar bear that was sniffing it's just
more satisfying to pull a trigger of a
gun than to just stand there and let the
elements take their toll and just watch
The Life seep out of him that's right by
the others and it's perfect because then
he's a ice zombie yes and thus the Game
of Thrones Assassin's Creed crossover is
complete done done and done uh do we
know when we're going to hear more about
this game or when it's going to come out
or anything like that well point in the
future August 20th no it's it's November
11th
this is
another this is the one that has to
coincide with unity the one that you
know all the people who don't have
current gen consoles are going to be
able to play and we just haven't heard
as much about it because you know they
want to pimp out unity and that does
look really cool and it's going to I'm
sure it's going to be a lot of fun but
this is the one most people are going to
buy because it's the one on the cult you
think so you think it'll out sell the
install Bas is like leaps and is
multiple times bigger 360 PS3 that but
then there's PC as far as we know un is
the only one coming to PC yeah
fortunately NPD only tracks retail sales
so that's true digital sales who cares
about I really wish they had chosen a
name that wasn't like a really common
developer platform for that Assassin's
Creed Assassin's Creed
unreal that been better how did you find
out the next yeah Assassin's Creed
Havoc uh all right last no story we're
going to talk about Assassin's Creed
Photoshop sorry last one last one I'm
Assassin Creed Maya you want one more
not last Maya would be great Assassin's
Creed Microsoft Office that would be
cool if they just make uh that Mel
Gibson Maya movie into an Assassin's
Creed thing so Assassin's Creed word
Apocalypto Assassin's Creed speaking of
Resident Evil a new Resident Evil game
was announced and uh it's not really new
it's old but new again all things old
made new through the magic of video
games uh what is what the deal here
what's it called Resident
Evil damn it
I'm I'm actually very cuty name for it
re remake the Resident Evil HD I would
assume hasn't there been like eight of
those already though so this is I I'm
actually pretty excited about that this
is the GameCube re-release that that
only came out on GameCube there was that
point many years ago when Capcom made an
agreement with Nintendo we're like we're
only going to bring some games out to
GameCube no other consoles we had
Beautiful Joe and Resident Evil and then
Capcom was like nobody's buying these
Resident Evil 4 was one of those games
and
res and then it came out to everything
else this was one of the games that
never came out to any of the other
consoles like playing Resident Evil
you've basically had to play the
PlayStation one version and that's it
and this this version looked really
great I mean all you can see from the
screens it was a great update I mean we
should say it is not a note fornote
remake of the original Resident Evil
they did some significantly different
things I remember it being much harder
on the GameCube uh it was it was a
little bit harder yeah but are you sure
you didn't just grow weak in your old
age
GameCube yeah I have uh grown weak to
challenges and any sort of like
significant well we saw you playing
Rogue Legacy earlier yeah it's a baby
game but if you had problems with the
controls or anything like that I think
it's interesting that they're going to
include the tank controls but if you
don't want the tank controls you can
control it like a real game um they're
also not one of those fake gamer games
not a not a tank you're not a tank when
you're you're not a tank you're a man or
woman they're also adding in a camera
that I guess will pan around so you'll
keep that cinematic view that you got in
the game but it'll kind of show make it
look more realistic in the way that it
transitions between stages but you can
also turn that off if you just want the
regular Resident Evil the slide by slide
spot yeah the fixed C well that fixed
camera was like for me it was like key
in making that really terrifying well I
think the fixed camera no matter what is
going to be in there but it's just the
way that it transitions between scenes
like when you go in a door it's just not
going to suddenly be like up in the
middle of nowhere It'll like slide over
so you can see how it yeah it's sort of
like is it's a gentle pan it's not you
know you're not moving it around or
anything like that all right are you
guys going to play it what you are you
no 100% yeah I I the Resident Evil
GameCube one has been sitting next to my
console and like I've been like I don't
want 13 years no I played it back in the
day and I'm like I want to play this
again but I don't want to bring out my
Wii and plug that in this is an excuse
not to have to do that and it's going to
be on PC so I don't have to worry about
not being like I can still let this sit
for another 13 years and won't have to
plug in something else I can just
download it on steam when it's going to
go on I'm going to wait for it to go on
sale okay and it's just going to sit
there and you won't play 13 years from
now I will play it perfect great I'm
just playing it so I can say I'm playing
three make get it it's the third I could
I could hear the r and the E were
capitalized three make three that was
even clear three it helps it it
definitely helps when your voice is like
lilting up and down like that it really
sells the that kind of inflection is
really wait wait three make we're going
to have we're going to Kevin Workshop
that a little bit but now we're going to
roll the actual announcement of the
Resident Evil situation we've been
talking about we're going to take a look
at that when we come back Dan rker from
giant bomb's going to join us on the
couch for some swapper action and
no no no ludd comments about that please
in advance let's go to the video
tape
G
for
PlayStation 4 PlayStation 3 Xbox
One
Gra
for
res re the three three make I don't know
it's apparently it's not called that
Kevin vanord all right we are back live
we've got Dan reer from Giant Bomb here
to show us the swapper and Sean also
here
contribute on what all is going in the
swapper but Dan I literally have heard
people Rave about this game but it's
still one that I have not taken the two
goddamn seconds to look up myself so
give me a little help here okay it was
made by like four people uh from face
palm games if I remember right they're
from all over you know there's a couple
in like Finland and Australia or
something I could be making that up but
I think there's four all right we take
madeup facts here on
theant but I first heard of this game at
paxis last year and a lot of people on
the floor were talking about how great
it was at the Indy mega Booth so I
stopped by there and like you know the
four developers or whatever were there
and I went in knowing nothing about it
and I played it immediately loved it
wound up reviewing it when I worked at
Game Informer and it was top 10 uh my
personal top 10 last year last year H
and uh yeah I'm actually really curious
I've not played the PS4 version so that
was on PC last year now it's coming to
the PS4 yes let's take a look here are
we going to start right from the
beginning believe that's the plan here
yeah I actually have not played this
since I reviewed it so uh I I'm curious
to see how it works with the controller
here see how your swapper chops are okay
swapper chops swap chops is what we call
them yeah yeah Sean set the stage for us
where are we here spinning void space
yep and that's it yeah cool good talk so
a lot of the visuals are kind of this
like clay and and found objects and it's
really got a a cool aesthetic to it
really yeah the whole game is very
atmospheric
too is that a space pun uh I did not
mean for it to be but if you'd like to
take it it that way you can we count all
puns intentional and otherwise okay
that's
fair so the uh the narrative here is
there there's not a whole lot of it
there's the occasional kind of cryptic
cryptic text or you know weird rock
thing you read a thing on doesn't really
matter it's all atmosphere and it's very
puzzle focused it's kind of the uh the
portal type thing to where you go into a
room it's kind of a self-contained
little puzzle and you just got to figure
out specifically how to how to finish
that up and you're launching off here in
your Tin Can rocket ship yes that is me
going to space station thus if I
remember right nice get that get that
swapper lore down yeah yeah it's
basically the Event Horizon game o event
that was a good movie Sam Neil yeah
Lawrence Fisher yeah yeah all right
you're touching down here are you I want
to ask you all these questions but
really just want to watch Well here
here's the thing I love about this game
is that all the mechanics are introduced
to you in the first 10 minutes here so
every item you're ever going to get I
mean there's no enemies in this game
there's one item you get it's a swapper
gun and it manages to make this whole
game really interesting with just this
one core mechanic the swapper
gun let see okay you learned how to jump
working got some slight camera control
here not too much uh First Impressions
upon the visual uh sort of fidelity here
on the PlayStation 4 pretty much
identical identical yeah so these little
guys here these are checkpoints mhm so
let's see all right it's going to be
really interesting once we get to the
actually getting the swapper gun cuz the
mouse was key to uh to maneuvering that
thing around and I'm curious
how some Metroid doors
there it's there's like a little Coral
thing almost going on on some of these
uh surfaces yep which I Coral Is My Jam
I'm all about it big Coral guy yeah I'm
a big Coral dude if you if you've seen
my Pinterest it is like strictly coral
and coral based art okay what about Reef
you like Reef yeah dude I'm I'm wav down
with Reef so I already have the swapper
gun and that looks like a cloner gun it
is seems to me like you're playing God
right now Dan rker well look at all my
guys here oh my goodness these are all
my dudes now wow these guys are great oh
those idiots are stuck come on guys all
right you got a whole team now yep okay
I think it's going to some of them are
going to die uh a lot of them are going
to die or they just wait have they
disappeared because you've gone to a new
area or did they are all just running in
one frame they will like kind of like
T1000 together with you if you uh you
form with them I believe yeah make
physical contact with clones so here we
go so we got a puzzle here so let's test
this out so I can make look I'm using
the right stick to uh to move this
little dot around and that's where I can
drop my clones off and they'll get stuck
on stuff like idiots and then I can use
him there and he's going to get stuck
there they move move as much as like
basically As you move yes yes so now and
then you're like see you later buddy
screw that guy he sucks go long so yep
up to see you later that part of my
Eternal
Soul with every one of you I leave
behind I become less of a man oh yeah
and when you go through the checkpoints
they all just kind of evaporate like
that okay yeah wow oh yeah this is kind
of the lower stuff so uh yeah space
stuff
whatever space space stuff whatever this
game is about puzzles
uh your your concern was a little bit
like oh well you know clicking with the
mouse is really easy
just yeah you can just like completely
murder these dudes whenever you want
to so they all died ass to mouth too
it's as they lived as they lived they
died doing what they loved okay I cannot
swap to them yet so they're all dead uh
soon we will get the ability to do the
swap Ray thing and that's you'll put
your body this is
this is like that one magician movie uh
the The Prestige yeah yeah the huge
acman thing okay so here we go so now
I'm stuck down here you would think but
I can create a fella and then I can do a
zappy thing and now I'm that fella
you're moving you traded up man yep so
watch I can go that old that other guy
was real old yeah yeah he's done now
he's just ch it's like a snake shedding
his skin see so now I'm him [__] that
last guy he doesn't matter okay blue
light you can't create clones in inside
the blue light right so let's see what
happens if you try you just can't even
it doesn't even do anything you can't do
anything so let's okay so see this turns
the blue light down so I can create a
fella over here swap to himate you call
him a fella I kind of call everyone
fellas I don't know want create this
little fella come on little fella clone
fella get up on that switch I don't know
why I have an accent all this I don't
know
either okay so I can't swap here I can't
uh you see I it's kind kind of blocking
that I can't swap to that guy oh is that
your Eternal Soul trying to beam through
you're getting pretty deep here I I just
love Soul jokes I I just like swapping
or solving puzzles need to our powers
combined it it is about collecting orbs
it's all kind of gated like think like
kind of a Mario 64 like you need X
number of stars to get to the next area
or whatever but it does have this kind
of you know Metroid style map um there
are some branching paths you can do but
you eventually need to get pretty much
everything yeah now question are you
skipping that lore because you've read
it before I have read all it before uh
it's just kind of intentionally cryptic
I mean there's not much of a story to
this game it's it's worth reading if
you're playing it I mean don't skip it
like I'm doing right now but yeah I've
read it before and I want to show off
some puzzles here which is the real meat
of this game uh you were mentioning
about the mouse controls earlier and
you're sort
of it's always funny eagerness to see if
clone Slaughter would be as easy it's
super easy certainly is easy but eminent
stranger has a question is wondering uh
how do you think these will Faire on
some of the later puzzles which require
quick Precision I think it'll do fine
having it mapped to either of these
triggers it's like either of these is
create either of these is Swap and like
I said this is literally my first time
playing it on this so it's it's fine
glad we have such experienced guests
coming on here to demo games you're done
you're done you're doing well that was
weird that whole situation what was that
that was a teleporter So eventually you
know like any kind of Metroid
Castlevania type game come ref to say
come on back around are you boycotting
that Sean is a cast I'm a castle roid
guy Castle roid Castle Vania Metroid
also D SW them swap swap them around
arguably more so perhaps yeah make do uh
but yeah it's totally like you can
teleport around and here's one of the
orbs I forget what the actual term for
them is ones can't collect orbs know
they cannot but I can turn the light off
and create a fella swap to the fella and
then you just have do you have to have
line of sight on the fella to swap or
does it have to be sort of the beam yeah
you see it'll get stuck up there okay
and it can't go through that red light
so it requires a little you know messing
around as do all good puzzle games true
and later on it does get to the point
where you'll walk into a room and you'll
see a puzzle and you'll stare at it and
be like well this is clearly a broken
puzzle like this game is broken this is
impossible you can't do this and you
just got to dick around with it for a
while just got to try stuff all you can
do I yeah any game that makes me doubt
my own uh sanity or like mental Acumen
is a game that I eventually come to like
and then when you solve or just dis
completely yeah yeah just put it down
and and never play it again yeah never
did have you ever played the swapper no
never never tried it no once nope it's
fantastic
game but yeah it makes you feel awesome
when you finally do solve some of those
later ones a that's a good feeling that
sweet satisfaction or like that first
glimmer where you're like yeah maybe
this is possible just have that you know
eure moment I think I can oh I think
this could this could work yep wait do I
need to call a thing drop some fellas in
there all right yeah don't have to twist
my arm see you
idiots oh boy oh the rampant fella
Carnage of the swapper I can swapper
them see I can keep making them swapping
them oh God I don't know how I get out
of this situation are you going to die
now yep I'm totally going to die yep
well you know got experiment a little
bit can you is that ever a thing you
have to do to like gain altitude like
SWAP SWAP SWAP SWAP SWAP and so you're
just killing all these dudes below you
and you look at the bottom there a pile
of dudes yeah it's so cool that was one
of the puzzles where I got to and I was
like how am I going to get up there and
I was like oh wait it doesn't actually
want me to do this does it and then I
realize it totally do it definitely does
yeah it wants you to create a litter of
clones so yeah these Dum rocks will talk
to you for some reason and say a bunch
of this mumbo jumbo uh do you think
there are large communities of swapper
like uh fiction people who sort of tease
out stories and create fanfic based in
the swap video game I'd have to imagine
there's some dorks that are doing that
yeah but uh God bless those dorks oh
yeah dorks are great love them but yeah
yeah I I wouldn't be reading that so
occasionally you'll get these things you
can drag them around some like limbo
crap ah yes that's seminal box pushing
Puzzler limbo mhm
quartin speaking of limbo are there bad
guys zero enemies there's no giant demon
spiders absolutely none uh I don't think
there's even any spikes to land on
although I might be wrong about that
there's some environmental hazards now
it's not like Metal Gear Solid 3 where
eventually there's a boss fight where
you fight all of your like the enemies
that you've killed that that would be
cool cuz that part's awesome in that
game your entire Clone Army just comes
back at you with a Vengeance that would
be so good okay so I am inhabiting this
guy on the right here yeah so I can't
swap to the guy up there because the
stupid red light so I'm going to try to
I can bring him over here I think I can
swap in blue but you can't project a I
can't make him there though you can swap
there so now I got another orb monogon
orb AC quied and this stuff Rock samples
yeah all right and you know how I'm so
down with extraterrestrial geography
yeah yeah I like space crab too it's
interesting quarantine okay so I turned
off
quarantine yeah there's okay there's a
couple more doors so those doors are you
know like you haven't gone here yet you
probably want to come check this out so
do you find yourself Consulting that map
like once you sort of get into thing
wait hold on Sean can we get a dramatic
reading here the world is the limit of
thought the limit of thought is the
chain of Heroes like me I cannot speak
if they cannot listen why do you have a
little bit of Bane in there I don't
know space anything
what is where how is where does we tick
questions we've all asked ourselves now
you have my permission to
swap it's pretty good yeah he's been
working on it so that was the whole
point of this room is uh is these rocks
talking to you so uh you do want to go
everywhere though if you see a door you
haven't gone in go into it there's
there's usually something there you want
to get some you want to get some rock
talk Rock talk yes it's morning Zoo crew
radio show
all right let's see Rock spelled with a
WK oh that's cool
yeah bad a okay so this I can make this
dude here okay this might be one of the
first tricky ones I can make him up
there but if I go too far right he's
gonna fall so he's stuck in there now so
he's safe in
there safe in his eternal tomb yes so
now he can go in there which means okay
that wasn't that bad I can swap up there
got another orp
you are rolling in monogon man yeah all
about that
monogon stacking monogon got three now
so now I'm going to go down there what
how many do you need to unlock the uh
roll power or the double jump yeah uh
the morall yeah you get that at six the
wave beam comes at 14 excellent yeah
just adhering to sort of the genre
standards you get the chain whip is that
something that happens eventually that
is in Castlevania that's a different
that's a different game what are you
even talking
yeah Sean this is when do the flying
chairs come after you you're a
professional gaming journalist this is
what are you doing sound like a damn
fool we have higher standards here
mckinness oh you'd think so so oh okay
oh God so you have to do some crap to
make sure you don't fall to your death
so let's let's try this again here so I
think it does like a little slow down
thing so I can go like yeah so when I'm
aiming it's like slow-mo so I can you
got do it real fast cuz you
can't I would have stayed in his body he
watched his Brethren die right in
front weren't even expecting that one
this game's great God the psychological
trauma of just watching you fall dead in
front of you actually some of the lore
or whatever does touch on that later on
like once it gets later on it goes to
like oh you're separating yourself into
all these places and how much of
yourself you lost that guy's probably
important nice oh yeah he's just in the
in the Stream mhm uh Mouser madness has
a question about this sort of touches on
the uh the timing based puzzles we had
earlier you know like are you are you
under a time limit here or is it just
certain puzzles require certain kinds of
timing like how does that it's timing
like like what I just did there in fact
let's just that was the one I was
referring to
earlier where this is early on this is
an early puzzle obviously I was like how
the hell do I get up there there's an
arrow pointing up and this is the the
one where I figured out that oh God you
actually have to do this thing and while
it's in slow-mo you have to place
yourself and then all those guys are
dead and so to place yourself and and
swap that's just a a tap a d a two two
tap yep so I'm holding in L1 here to
kind of place it so I'm going to let go
of L1 and tap R1 right away but you also
need to go right back to L1 to
activate and then let go R1 and then and
then everybody dies hooray figure out
that sweet spot where I can actually
live and fall so the swappers out on PC
and now out on PlayStation 4 and I
believe it's Vita too I think it's a
cross by cross save get a sort of that
Rogue Legacy thing that we were talking
about earlier just all across the
PlayStations on the main menu there was
a Cloud sync button so which um yeah I
wonder on the Vita I'm not sure uh if
you could do some like tap to uh like
tap the screen like hey I want a guy
there I want a guy there I haven't
played it on V yet so that would be neat
let us know folks if you've uh played
this on the vitao last question from
template response how about how long
would you take to sort of explore all
this if you can recall it's been over a
year since I reviewed it probably
distant dark cold Winters yes yes you
spent playing the swapper in the
Hinterlands Hinterlands Hinterlands is
that a word oh yeah yeah oh wow I didn't
know that okay uh I would guess five or
six okay yeah Co I mean it's super worth
it get it it's just an awesome puzzle
game I mean some of the puzzles really
do rival the best ones in the portal I
thought um so yeah I I loved every
second one of Dan rikard's games of the
year yes 2013 cool that's the swapper
folks uh we're going to close her up at
the show here talking about giving away
PlayStation 4s if you were uh watching
the lobby last week you knew that we
were uh doing this sort of mural thing
with Sony on greatness aws.com in which
you get to sort of put yourself into one
of these uh gaming murals they created
with a bunch of Sony characters and and
in like a painting like Washington
crosses the Delaware or a few options
like that on greatness aws.com so I
naturally I did it and uh here you can
see me leading the charge uh yep just
like standing next to my my man Pig
murder guy ATT not good not good what
look I've got Joel at the front and
Agent 47 Chris it looks like you're
pooping in the the Delaware right now
listen it' be in the boat It's a Long
Boat Ride okay you think Washington ever
pooped in the Delaware yes no you don't
think so I don't think Washington ever
pooped in the Delaware listen uh we're
going to look forward to your volume
three of Scat history uh American
history version your European history
version was actually pretty incredible
uh thoroughly researched thoroughly
researched so you can make one of those
of yourself you can send it around to
your friends I tried to do it with like
a zombie face on but had a little
trouble with the makeup but I think I
got a pretty good Noble leading the
video game characters charge thing going
on there pooping into a river entering
on that site allows you to win a play
enter enter win a PlayStation 4 uh from
Sony as well as a print out of your
mural but we also are running our own
sort of version of it and uh getting you
guys to submit your greatest gaming
moments to us using the hashtag my
greatest gaming moments and uh send your
mural to us use that hashtag send it to
at Gamespot we're giving away our very
own PS4 you don't have to enter the pool
of all the greatness weights people you
can enter the select pool of Gamespot
folks who could win a PS4 what's your
hashtag greatest gaming moment my
hashtag greatest gaming moment yeah was
it the time that you beat King Yama
after I beat King Yama or I think it was
the time sure it it might have been the
time that like uh like a benevolent
father figure I ushered you to uh into
the final boss of Spelunky and you were
definitely you were my Obi-Wan I got to
give you credit where credit is due you
know but then you did you know you did
outperform me in the end uh so back at
you buddy yes Spelunky are definitely
some of my greatest gaming moments all
those are playable on sod systems as
well uh so once again send us a tweet
using the hasht greatest gaming moment
to enter to win a PlayStation 4 from Gam
spot and then go over to greatness.com
to create your own mural and enter to
win a PlayStation 4 and a picture of
yourself making a funny face while
crossing the Delaware or there's like
another one charging through battle and
then there's another one in the sky or
something like that I don't know you can
check it out and win stuff uh Sean have
you ever won anything Dan ever won
anything in a
contest I won like a plaque one time it
that was like it was at one of these
like summer Outreach programs you go to
like do trust Falls and stuff yeah I won
like a commemorative plaque was not
thrilling I want to say that before I
started Gamespot I won a Photoshop
contest on
joystick.ru my mom made me take her dog
up to accept a second place trophy for
smallest dog when I was a child and I
tripped on the stair and my dog went
across the stage and yeled real loud and
I felt real
stupid well that was a delightful
anecdote gosh I will cherish that memory
forever of little Dan tripping and
causing a tiny dog to run across the
stage fly fly across the stage you were
holding the dog I was holding the dog
even better even better uh and then you
swapped to the dog and it was actually
you yelping yes exactly it's like they
say if you love something throw it
across the room if it comes back in
front of a large crowd yeah in front of
a large crowd you're the mortification
of all yeah Wonderful Life advice Sean
very touching all right folks good luck
in that PlayStation 4 contest I hope you
win and then send us a picture of you
with a PlayStation 4 don't be like going
up to accept any awards while you do it
cuz you know it's bad news you might you
might end up pulling a record or just be
graceful Dan I want to thank you you for
coming up here and showing uh the
swapper I had a good time game looks
really cool uh I'm sure we'll have you
back on as the fall grows onward to talk
about giant bomb stuff and uh all the
great games that are coming out or maybe
going to get delayed I don't know if
there's going to be some more evolved
situations Sean thanks man thank you
good times on the lobby this week next
week Daniel DWI still on vacation so
I'll be back hosting we got a bunch of
games lined up for you to see then so
come on back next Tuesday at 2 pm for
more Lobby we'll see you
then are you play
these
guys